well did you read the fouchy emails yes
the freedom of information emails that's
really crazy
because well he first of all he's
admitting
in these emails that masks don't work
he's wesley yes
yeah he talks about it talked about it
openly oh wait i didn't know that part i
know i only
here's i thought you were going to talk
about the uh that too but here's the
thing
but part of the email was look part of
the masked conversation with fauci
has always been that at the beginning of
the pandemic he said masks didn't work
but then he said the reason he said that
is because there wasn't enough mass for
first responders and hospital staff
and he didn't he wanted to make sure
that the supply wasn't damaged so he
said that he
didn't tell the truth right okay but in
these emails
he's also this is private emails he's
saying masks don't work
for real yes he's saying that they're
not effective for what you
outside of a hospital setting these
masks like for personal use the kind of
cloth masks and
paper masks that everybody's wearing
they're not effective they're not
they can't exactly what did he say let's
let's pull it up exactly what he said
but that's not even the big part the big
part is
he's talking about gain of function
research in the wuhan lab
and he's concerned about it and thinking
whether or not they had paused that
and whether they're still doing that and
he's trying to connect the gain of
function research in the wuhan lab
with this covet breakout and whether or
not that's where it came from
right and why is that a big deal because
that's they funded it
the nih funded these people who funded
the gain of function research
in the wuhan lab which means they're
responsible
for funding the very research that led
to this outbreak if that's where it came
from
right so all this time when he's been
saying it came from nature there's no
way it came from a lab well you know
that's
shifted right now everybody's saying
from a lab
right right right but they're not
confirmed right
but the evidence is pointing yeah as
it's most likely that it came from a lap
this whole time fauci has been saying it
didn't but you see in his emails
that he was concerned well concerned but
isn't that
but isn't that like just trying to
figure out what the information is
not really because he doesn't
definitively know either right
there's a lot of indications according
to the email he's talking to another
scientist
right and the scientist points out the
variables
or the the the um the components of the
virus
that seem to indicate that it possibly
came from a lab
but publicly he's been out now
dismissing that
because yeah he's connected to the very
research they were doing there
uh-huh it's really complicated [ __ ] it's
confusing because rand paul's been
grilling them
have you seen those things hey girls
typical mask you by the drugstore is not
really effective in keeping out the
virus
which is small enough to pass through
the material it might however provide
some slight benefit in keeping out gross
droplets if someone coughs or sneezes on
you
i do not recommend that you wear a mask
particularly since you're going to
a very low risk location see this is
just him
saying that these drugstore masks are
not really effective
but this is this is in an email after he
has said
publicly that you didn't have to wear
masks because
they didn't really help and then he's
saying this and
after that he said well he wasn't
telling the truth there because he
didn't want people to buy all the masks
but then he's saying this after that
right in an email that they don't really
work
but yet he's wearing them but that's
kind of like that's there is shades in
that
there's like the gross droplets gross
droplets
and if you're in a low risk location
like what's his motivation to
like why would he profess masks if he
thought well because
the narrative is everybody needs to mask
up but why like well because it makes
people feel safer
a it helps people get back to work b and
it
obviously is providing some benefit
something
listen this is my take on it something's
happening because the flu cases are down
so low oh yeah so is that because of
people wearing masks
is that because of social distancing
because everybody's kind of freaked out
and stayed away from each other for so
long
washing their hands everywhere they go
getting having having
purely everything i don't think that
every spot i don't think that's it
because it's a
you're talking about something that's
airborne well for that but for you to
get a cold
you know your hands and your [ __ ] all
those things
all those things yeah maybe but there's
something
something there's very well likely
something to masks that maybe we weren't
aware of so
even what he's saying there that it
might just keep out gross droplets
yeah but isn't it all about like viral
load
because like that's the thing they say
about a hospital workers like hospital
workers when they're
they're exposed to so much right that's
when they go somewhere
and they really get sick yeah maybe
that's what these masks are good for
what is this
yeah get that there you go um which are
the protective measures anyone should
take against the new virus do mass work
he said
the vast majority of people outside
china do not need to wear a mask
red the fouchy approved response a mask
is more appropriate for someone who's
infected than for people trying to
protect against infection
right well i mean what's but like what's
my whole thing with all of this is it's
been very confusing
we're all every governor's making
decisions everybody's
around the world is trying to figure
[ __ ] out and calling a lockdown and
calling not a lockdown
everyone's like unlimited information
trying to make the best decisions that
they can like i don't think that
as a governor of a state you're making a
decision to screw up the economy on
purpose
i don't think that i don't think that
fauci is talking about mass
to like harm people you know what i mean
like i
just feel like i feel like they're just
have limited information
and are trying to muddle their way
through the best that they can
like what that's not the real problem is
the mass thing it's a small problem the
real problem is this gain of function
research [ __ ]
this is the the very research that they
were doing where they were just what
they were juicing up these viruses to
make them more infectious and they were
practicing like trying to use i think
they use human lung tissue
and try to get the virus to be more
the idea is i mean i'm going to butcher
this for sure but i think the idea is
when they're doing this research they
want to find out what makes these
viruses
more infectious and they were doing it
on the original sars as well
yeah which has like a 10 fatality rate
wow it's very scary wow this stuff is
less than one percent yeah
that stuff is way worse yeah and by
doing this gain of function research
they run the risk of people getting sick
we just found out a couple of weeks ago
that in november of 2019 three workers
from the lab in wuhan
got sent home and sent to the hospital
rather
really ill with coronavirus-like
symptoms
and this was before they had covid19
tests right uh-huh so these people got
sent home
i believe one of the guys wives died
from kovid
and they think this was the initial
infection so these people in the lab
got sick so all this time while they
were trying to dismiss
this lab outbreak that had been hidden
from us
that these three people in the lab got
sick the fact that
fauci had something to do with that gain
of function research and funding that
gain of function research
that had kind of been hidden from well
that makes it josh rogan exposed that
but that makes it seem like fauci's like
putting on scrubs and walking down the
halls of that
place you know what i mean like is fauci
really like in there like
you know what i mean like are you
defending voucher
yeah like i don't know i think that he's
been put up as
a someone we can take our fears and
anger and throw it at
but is he like he may be part of like
you know these things are
huge like there's a big board of people
that decide what they're going to
research and you got to read these
emails you got to read these emails and
now read so do you think that he's evil
do you think
no i'm not saying that so what do you
what do you say i think someone [ __ ]
up
i think they're trying to cover up the
fact they [ __ ] up uh okay i think the
whole reason why they've been saying
that this thing
came from nature it's a natural
spillover
is i don't think they're saying that
because that's the most likely scenario
i think they were saying that because
they [ __ ] up right
now they did they didn't want everyone
to know
that they [ __ ] up and i think having
the position of power
and having the position of authority
that he had
he could say it does no indication this
came from a lab
who is they who [ __ ] up like what is
this well the lab
in wuhan for sure [ __ ] okay so who runs
that lab
well i don't know but i do know that the
nih
funded an organization they gave money
to an organization which gave money to
that lab that's
that's the official story got it and
this is the story that
paul talked about when he was grilling
fauci
this is also what josh rogan talked
about right journalists that
investigated all this
what josh what rogan was saying was that
during the trump administration
everything was so chaotic
that they just kind of they were able to
restart this this kind of dangerous
research that obama had put the brakes
on
obama apparently like what the [ __ ] are
you doing uh-huh why are you why are you
making viruses more deadly
oh really stop and then
try to do this trump was over there
going home number one i'm the best
and they're like i got an idea let's
start that [ __ ] research back let it
fly
i don't know virus force some i mean
it's interesting because uh some
it's interesting news organizations are
ignoring it completely
and uh other organizations are attacking
it's
that's when you see like whether or not
the news is really the news
because you see the difference between
the way the left-wing news is covering
it which is a lot of them are just out
now ignoring it
yeah and the right-wing news coverage
they're constantly bringing up these
emails
right pulling them out and saying
hashtag firefoxy and all this different
yeah yeah well that's the thing it's
like once you start once you start
um calling out like this is our side's
thing like
i saw that there was a headline in the
new yorker or the new york times
that said why it's important to why it's
so important to figure out whether this
lab theory is correct
or not and it was like that was kind of
the first time i saw it
in those in those papers oh no it wasn't
it was in newsweek a couple months ago
no but i'm sorry that was like the first
that was the first fire yeah yeah
because you said when you see it on the
cover of newsweek when they started to
consider it again
yeah yeah but it was political yeah it's
totally political trump was such
he was such a polarizing figure that
and people hated him so much that
anything that guy said
everybody was like [ __ ] him let's go the
other way right he said it came from a
lab that it definitely didn't come from
a [ __ ] lab
yeah well that's the problem that's the
boy that cried wolf
syndrome right it became like exactly he
kind of did that to himself
he just keeps saying such crazy [ __ ]
that everybody was just in making it and
calling out everybody and yelling
meanwhile fauci just wrote a book so
he's releasing a book on this now
making money off of a book oh yeah
and he's also the same guy that told us
we wouldn't ever shake hands again
i think he's adorable though he's little
he's got like a little like a bronx kind
of thing going i got an action figure
somebody sent me a crouchy action figure
yeah with a mask on it has a mask
sitting on my desk
he's adorable he's funny he put him out
there he's like
you know there's like oh look i would
love to know
what that would like okay so if we're
trying to get into the truth of it which
is what we need right we need to know
obviously you and me are not going to
get into the truth of it please i'll
just you could tell me the fact right
now and i'll forget it by the next
subject
but if they're trying to figure that out
like who is behind wuhan like who is
making those decisions to do all this
stuff like
and how far is that a global thing like
is the u.s a huge part of it was
was norway really involved like who well
they have a bunch i don't know what it
is
apparently that do this kind of work
yeah and they do uh different kinds of
work at different kinds of labs and the
real fear
is that in like some labs in the world
some
places in the world they do weaponized
virus work god which means terrifying
that's terrifying which is terrifying
they did that in russia
for sure we actually covered that on
this sci-fi show that i hosted years
back
oh yeah it covered the idea of
weaponized viruses
but the thing that they told me when we
went to uh the cdc
down in uh galveston texas they have
this big building where they house
basically every [ __ ] terrible disease
known to man big thick ass walls and
ventilation systems and
everyone's wearing spacesuits and me and
duncan are high as [ __ ] wandering around
this place
you brought duncan yeah i mean duncan
went down there oh that's great
and uh the guy was saying that what he's
really worried about more than anything
is the things that come from nature
he's like we could worry all day about
weaponized viruses and he goes
but the possibility of that is low
compared to the possibility of something
jumping from nature which is very high
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost all
for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience